finally Inquisitor marok is the next big
thing in Star Wars I think again turns
out this franchise has got a real bad
guy problem the Star Wars franchise has
developed a nasty habit of wasting cool
characters before they've realized their
full potential if a villainous
characteristic brooding silent type
chances are they'll be disposed of
pretty quickly unfortunately this trend
is continued with Ahsoka which kills off
the mysterious Inquisitor of maroc in
episode 4. the unfortunate moment occurs
when Ahsoka Tano slices the inquisitor's
mid-rift during a chaotic lightsaber
battle in a forest afterward marak
disappears Into Thin Air presumably said
never return again the green smoke that
accompanies its disappearance also
suggests that maroc is a zombie who was
created by the Knight sisters of
dothamir which should end the theory
that is actually Ezra Bridger in
Disguise while the nature of marook's
death serves to enhance the law of the
galaxy far far away his exit from Ahsoka
feels a little premature he's
essentially the series version of the
original Boba Fett and Captain phasma
both of whom also suffered under filming
stories in the grand scheme of things so
does Star Wars have an issue when it
comes to creating compelling arcs for
its coolest mysterious characters let's
look at the history starting with the
Bounty Hunter Boba Fett his first
appearance in The Empire Strikes Back
led us to believe that he was going to
be a formidable villain but he turned
out to be pretty much useless as
evidenced by his anti-climactic fall
into the sarlac pit in Return of the
Jedi
send the leader Star Wars sequel Trilogy
introduces Captain phasma as a powerful
Stormtrooper who seems like she's going
to be a constant thorn in Finn and race
sight unfortunately Fazbear has killed
off rather abruptly in The Last Jedi of
course the book of Boba Fett's series on
Disney plus and the phasma novel add
more depth to their respective
characters backstories but that doesn't
mean that they weren't wasted from the
get-go and it remains to be seen if
marwark will get his own expanded Story
down the line what Ahsoka presents
marork as a serious threat his death in
episode 4 means that the show has missed
an opportunity to dig into his Origins
his association with Morgan ellsbeth and
the daughters of dathomir implies that
he's a knight brother a society whose
history hasn't already been covered in
great detail in the live-action Realm of
the Star Wars franchise everyone loves a
little mystery of course but the end of
marwick has robbed fans of the perfect
vehicle to explore the side of the Star
Wars Galaxy moreover my work is an
Inquisitor meaning that he was once part
of an elite death squad and an heir to
the Sith while the Armed Force death per
se inquisite are perfectly capable of
using elements of the force to inflict
damage on their opponents sadly Ahsoka
doesn't give this villain an opportunity
to really showcase his abilities outside
of a couple of fight scenes Ahsoka
eliminates him with relative ease too
which just adds to the notion that my
work was created to be a throwaway
character granted it's possible that
Ahsoka will unveil more marork asque
assassins down the line Morgan Balin
skull and shin horti need soldiers to
Aid them in their quest to find Grand
Admiral thrawn after all that said my
work is an inherently core character who
got fans speculating and losing him has
brought an end to some interesting
discourse and Marek's death has
certainly spurred some funds to share
their views one to the user writes Alas
poor maruk we barely knew ye another
record that sentiment stating that the
character had lots of potential to grow
and develop they wrote I think a former
Inquisitor term mercenary could be a
super cool recurring character in Star
Wars lore potential for a new Boba Fett
level of mysterious badass that said
while many fans were sad to say goodbye
to Inquisitor one redditor believes that
marik's death is actually quite fitting
for someone of his ilk they wrote can't
escape The Inquisitor tradition of going
out like a punk against Ahsoka I guess
foreign